the Mediterranean island of spin alonga
was once used to isolate lepers from the
mainland Rose believes fingerprint
Island may have been built for a similar
purpose you get a very similar layout
it's asymmetrical they're these tiny
little compounds this labyrinth theme
layout it's meant to keep people in
but as ROS closes in on fingerprint
island all is not as it seems from the
satellite image but is this that's it
these aren't dwellings I mean there's a
couple little structures there but they
look like temporary places with shade so
I think we can throw the leper colony
out the window I really need to get a
look at this place up close
ROS head straight to the nearest section
of crumbling wall if you look at the
wall it doesn't have any mortar it's all
dry stone it hasn't been been locked
into place they're just kind of lumping
giant rocks on top of each other it's a
vital clue to the island's purpose ho
Island in fact is full of these long
strips these are agricultural fields
these are not dwellings these dry stone
walls are not weight-bearing they're not
used for structural purposes but rather
their primary purpose is to clear the
ground of debris once the ground has
been cleared in this way it's ready for
growing crops but agriculture requires
water and the satellite image shows no
evidence of streams or lakes
Rose searches for clues and soon makes a
discovery yes
Eureka it's a well then how it all makes
sense this is why they're here on the
island because there's fresh water
there's a source of fresh water here the
next step is to figure out what the
farmers were growing on this island and
whether they left any clues in the soil
yep and this pretty much answers the
question what were they growing here
this is an old grapevine the labyrinth
seen from space is a weird vineyard
dating back hundreds of years it's an
interesting choice to put a vineyard on
an island probably one of the most
remote and bizarre vineyards ever this
soil Romanian there's a source of fresh
water here is perfect for growing grapes